ein wunderschöner morgen erwartet uns
hier in unserer kleinen süßen micro
fällt meine lieben freunde wir dürfen
gar nicht lang zeit verlieren denn in
der heutigen episode haben wir mal
wieder extrem viel auf unserer to do
liste zuallererst benötigen wir einige
fichten holzstufen fichtenholz falschen
habe ich bereits und ich muss mir auch
direkt noch einige fichten holztreppen
machen da sollten vier stück auf jeden
fall ausreichen denn ich habe mir
gedacht da das hier vorne auf unserer bh
also unser angel und bootshütte ja ein
bisschen der bootssteg ist macht es auf
jeden fall sind wir vorne noch ein
kleines bild
[Musik]
warum ich da geht man sogar ich hab
keine ahnung wurde idiot ist allerdings
konzentrieren wir uns weiterhin auf
unser erstes ziel in der heutigen
episode denn dafür benötige ich zunächst
einmal wie viel bekomme ich heraus drei
stück ich brauche noch eins mehr nämlich
vier fichtenholz schilder dann benötige
ich auch jetzt erst mal meine hier habe
ich noch auf jeden fall welche und ich
glaube das sollte doch schon reichen wir
benötigen auf jeden fall auch noch ein
bisschen wolle
denn ich habe mir gedacht und das konnte
ja gerade nicht zu ende bringen da
dieser komische idiot mit seinen
mistgabel mich da wieder okay wir haben
du bist doch grad rausgegangen wieso
sollte wie die dankeschön
ich habe mir gedacht da wieder vorne ja
unseren kleinen boot stieg haben werde
ich ein zwei drei vier fünf sechs wolle
eben ganz trotzdem
und jetzt ist er hier wie hier sagt sie
wolle hin dann bekommen wir ein weißes
banner und das sollten jetzt auch
eigentlich alle materialien seien die
wir benötigen um unser ziel für heute
bzw
erstes ziel für heute erst mal fertig zu
bauen nämlich wollte ich hier vorne ein
kleines bisschen hin bauen
ich packe euch mal die inspiration wo
ich mir das geholt habe und in die
kommentare und zwar fangen wir jetzt
hier an mit einer fichtenholz falsche
platzieren daneben eine fichtenholz
stufe und hier neben wieder eine
fichtenholz falltür hier drauf kommen
nun auf zwei schichten holzstufen das
hier vorne an den ecken diese treppen
habe ich nur hingesetzt damit ich die
stufen dort dran verzieren kann also die
werde ich auf jeden fall kurz wieder
einsammeln in die mitte hiervon kommt
und einreichen holzzaun auf den eichen
holzzaun
da ziehen wir von der seit jetzt einfach
mal ein weißes banner so dass wir wenn
wir von dort vorne drüberfahren das hier
sehen normalerweise wäre es jetzt schon
fertig allerdings habe ich dafür noch
ein bisschen fichtenholz schneller da
können wir beispielsweise ich hier mal
einen packen dann hier auf die seite
zack und dann noch hier vorne auf der
seite genau das gleiche das ist so ein
bisschen sonne
rehling sag ich mal so ein bisschen und
hier vorne packe ich jetzt noch mal eine
erde hin und hier vorne auch um die ecke
eine erde denn dort erstmal noch eine
erde drauf gibt es muss ein bisschen
höher
und jetzt sehen wir unsere fichtenholz
treppen und platzieren hier vorne noch
mal eben eine und hier auf der anderen
seite auch immer wenn ich im wasser bin
habe ich jetzt bisschen schiss ist
irgendwie weg dass sie jetzt auf jeden
fall unser schiff denn hier vorne ist
sieht auf jeden fall ganz neues
ausfindig also wenn wir von hier mal
gucken liegt auf jeden fall ganz cool
aus und wenn wir dann hier vorne von der
tier insel im east river fahren sehen
wir halt direkt nach guck mal hier ist
ein brötchen und dann haben wir unseren
normalen brötchen und die tiere insel
ist auch direkt der ort wo wir als
nächstes hin von müssen allerdings hab
ich keine schaufel so ich hab euch jetzt
gerade eine etwas längere timeless
eingeblendet beziehungsweise ich weiß
nicht wie lange sie war allerdings habe
ich mir ein paar sachen vorbereitet die
sache ist allerdings dass das noch immer
nicht genügend sachen sind denn ich will
was bauen was mir in die kommentare
geschrieben dass und das finde ich eine
ganz gute idee denn ich habe mir
überlegt beziehen wir sind mir wurde
gesagt das habe ich mir nicht überlegt
allerdings habe ich das in der tat schon
vorbereitet und das wird ganz gut
aussehen werden dort auf der insel ein
kleiner friedhof wäre denn in der
letzten folge der ein oder andere kann
sie eventuell erinnern sind einige tiere
leider verstorben mit denen wir auf der
insel unterwegs waren
und wieso ist dieses portier das muss
auch zu unserer bhs kannst ja nicht
angeht auch genau wie schön dass sie
aussieht das schweinchen nach vorne mit
mit den bienen die legal wir bringen das
bildchen hierüber wir packen das einfach
mal hier fordert der seite hier sind
allerdings echt schon ein bisschen stau
steigen allerdings ganz kurz aus und wir
sehen auch schon die sonne geht unter
von daher gehe ich mal ganz fix schlafen
und danach die bereits gerade schon
gesagt muss ich noch mal wissen was ich
hab's noch nicht gesagt allerdings habe
ich noch nicht alle items an start denn
um diesen friedhof zu bauen muss ich
eine menge steine haben denn friedhöfe
passen irgendwie ganz gut mit steinen
beieinander keine ahnung was ich dafür
noch mal ganz kurz in die höhle beziehen
wir so unsere mine unten deswegen euch
darf auch noch mal eine ganz kurze time
labs
[Musik]
im 1
ich glaube wir sollten langsam mal hoch
gehen ich bin einfach hier runter in die
mine gegangen weil ich eine menge steine
brauchte für den friedhof allerdings die
[Musik]
kunden zu uns weiß dass der uns antreten
wird wahrscheinlich der macht gar nichts
treffen sich normalerweise an der tut
uns gar nichts mit ein paar sekunden
später
man hört leiter geräusch aber er kriegt
es nicht immer gut dann ist das unser
neues kleines schleimen haustier wasser
und am ende - jetzt warten wird um ein
quad ok krass ich dachte die reifen ein
anderer bei der ist anscheinend bisschen
friedlicher die sache ist allerdings
dass sich diese ganzen steine brauchte
um den friedhof fertigzustellen
und da ist halt das problem dass ich dir
jetzt alle erstmal was macht
er guckte gegen die verbirgt warum haben
wir noch keine ahnung warum hier ein
loch ist ich mach das mal ganz kurz zu
und werde mich auch mal die alles klar
ich werde nicht mal direkt schlafen
legen beziehungsweise wird dafür auch
mal hier kurzen das häuschen gehen da
hinterher oft probleme gehabt mit
krippen die da plötzlich auch gott kann
ich jetzt überhaupt schlafen wenn du
dich braucht man denn er ist es eine
kleine spinne aber ich muss dich töten
weil ich schlafen will
ja ich mache mal ganz kurz dazu wir
müssen erstmal noch den ganzen dings
hier reinpacken überall in die öfen
damit wir die ganzen steine überhaupt
fertig gebraten kriegen um dann
schlussendlich unsere bruch ich mache
ich den ganzen ich mir schon wie das
hier heute kämpfen leute 2 max
wie kann das sein kann dass sein es ist
taghell
ich hab ihn nicht gesehen weil er so
grün war wie alles was hier stand
umgekehrt das grab nicht angerührt
das kann doch nicht sein dass wir in
jeder folge hier immer irgendwelche
schäden an unserer welt haben man diese
armagh gerieten die herumstanden hitze
lockt eine ich habe jetzt allerdings
keine zeit mich darum zu kümmern wir
müssen erst mal hat das war schon am
ende der folge müssen uns erst mal ist
wirklich um das kümmern was eigentlich
der plan ist eder vorne richtig auch
dieser zeit sprachen
er ist mir egal ich finde das boot
schlagen nicht sie müssten wenig kunden
von unten geht's okay gut ich dachte
schon ich muss jetzt die schildkröten
töten damit ich mein boot zurück kriege
ich will natürlich nicht dass sie sich
da vorne bei mir einsetzen ich will
allerdings auch nicht dass hier vorne
sein boot verwahrlost rumsteht und dass
sie dann da irgendwie keine ahnung davon
haben aber auch schon kleinen stau
naja als auch egal wir sind auf jeden
fall fertig vorbereitet meine lieben
freunde denn das allererste was ich
machen möchte möchte ist hier vorne den
baum abreisen denn hier kommt da er auf
die insel auch ein grab hinkommt habe
ich mir gedacht passt hier auch ganz
gute kleine kirche hin
da habe ich mich schon was rausgesucht
das werde ich allerdings in der heutigen
folge nicht mehr schaffen wahrscheinlich
auch nicht in der nächsten folge die
nächste folge wird weil wieder eine
komplette time labs folge sein denke ich
mal in der ich mir eine menge items
zusammensammeln muss denn wir haben als
ziel ja immer noch etwas was hinter
dieser insel stattfinden soll wird denke
ich was ich meine
das möchte ich demnächst endlich mal
fertig umsätzen von daher kommt dieser
baum hier weckt das hat ja nicht so
richtig geklappt dass wir so einen
riesenbaum anfängt zu wechseln da
meinten
hk zu regnen aber das ist einfach nur
wenn man hier unter einem schatten ist
mir wird auf jeden fall gesagt dass man
anstatt eichen setzlingen ganz einfach
diese tropen baumsetzlinge nehmen soll
davon habe ich allerdings glaube ich
keine
dafür müssten wir bei ihnen wann endlich
in den dschungel gehen und daraus kann
man dann irgendwie sich so einen fetten
baum hier wachsen lassen allerdings
nachts nicht mehr hey wenn wir jetzt da
hinten schon eine dingens bauen eine die
dass ich erst mal stehen weil wir da
hinten jetzt schon den friedhof bauen
dann passt seine kapelle beziehungsweise
eine kirche ja auch ganz gut und der
friedhof solche vorne stattfinden
warum ist dass sie keinen der friedhof
soll hier vorne stattfinden meine lieben
freunde dafür möchte ich erst mal ganz
kurz die die ganze bäume abfällen denn
wir brauchen auf jeden fall ein bisschen
platt alles weitere mit der drumherum
bemalung nicht bemalung mit der
drumherum bepflanzung und so kommt
erstmal nachdem ihr den friedhof fertig
haben und ich möchte auch hier vorne
diese ebene hier abtragen mit dem witz
mehr platz haben wir haben natürlich
schon einige tiere auf unserer
verstorbenen liste jetzt könnt auch alle
nur ein weg rumstehen umziehen
[Musik]
ich idiot hat natürlich wieder nicht
mehr bettchen dabei von daher erstmal
wieder ganz fix hierüber zu unserer
insel noch mal eben kurz schlafen gehen
die sache ist jetzt allerdings dass sich
schon wieder schiss habe weil es ja
schon ein bisschen dunkel ist dass wir
hier schon wieder monster am start haben
das gute sei allerdings dass wir hier
vorne auch unser bettchen drin haben und
ich werde mir dieses bettchen jetzt auch
gleich mitnehmen auf die tier insel plus
was mir auch mit wem werde ist definitiv
doch hier eine kiste
das macht auf jeden fall sind da ich
gerade schon wieder gemerkt habe ob gott
wir haben doch wieder eine menge items
am start erfolg am salat schild soll er
da zählen eigentlich habe ich mir fürs
heutige video auch noch vorgenommen dass
ich eine menge materialien wir noch
zusammen suchen werden a time labs die
wir für den leuchtturm benötigen das
habe ich ja vorhin schon gesagt werde
angedeutet dass ich denen einer der
nächsten folgen auf jeden fall bauen
möchte das sind allerdings extrem viele
materialien um euch nur mal ganz kurz zu
sagen was wir zum beispiel
zusammengesucht werden muss 66 weiter
beton 66 roter beton das sind allein
schon irgendwie 700 betonblöcke die wir
benötigen und das wird wirklich extrem
extrem extrem viel arbeit von der
welches heute denke ich nicht mehr
schaffen ich sortiere erst mal ein paar
sachen hier ein die ich hier auf der
insel nun erstmal nicht benötigen werde
beziehungsweise während ich jetzt den
links bauer während ich jetzt den
friedhof bauer deswegen hier erst mal so
ein idiot meinte zu mir
er fängt an zu brennen und leute 2 max
[Musik]
ich bin
weg
[Musik]
er erzählt das problem so ein bisschen
auf der insel hier sind überall bäume
deswegen können sich darunter perfekt
hat irgendwelche monster verstecken
ich hoffe allerdings dass die jetzt alle
mal tot sind also wie ich packen hier
ganz kurz neben unseren mut ein bisschen
knochen sind gut denn wir benötigen nach
auf jeden fall noch ein bisschen
knochenmehl und ich werde hier vorne
jetzt auch erstmal noch die ganzen
blumen wegtragen beziehungsweise kann
mir auch erst mal kurz stehen lassen
damit ich euch erst mal ganz kurz zeigen
wo die reise überhaupt hingehen soll
denn der eingang solche vorne sein der
eingang zu unserem friedhof das soll
nämlich keiner normaler kein normaler
kein normales grab werden wie wir das
bisher hatten sondern ich möchte da hat
mir wirklich ein bisschen mühe bei dem
von anfang an direkt mal ich hab das mal
vor gebaut bei mir in meiner test welt
wieder
ich werde nie notiere im weg auch weg
ist es bürgermeister ist der
bürgermeister so machen wir das jetzt
einfach mal und der weg kommt dann hier
vorne so lange hier vorne kann ich noch
keinen weg machen dann muss ich warten
bis das hier grün wird und hier vorne
ist denn der eingang zu dem friedhof in
den habe ich mir gedacht machen wir so
bis beziehungsweise stellen wir sogar in
dem das so ein bisschen aussehen soll
wie sonne geöffnete tür jetzt natürlich
dass hier ein bisschen doof
wir lassen das erstmal hier fordern die
seiten kommen jetzt so ein bisschen habe
ich noch ein bisschen erde nie habe ich
nicht glaube kunst gestalten ja danke
wir können wir können uns ja mal ganz
kurz eben hoch bauen und das hier vorne
auch nochmal mit den treppen machen hier
von der anderen seite natürlich auch
hier eine dagegen und hier oben um auf
einer hinter muss ich mir jetzt mal ganz
kurz hoch bauen ich habe mir bestimmt
wieder meinen gerüst nicht mitgenommen
so ein bisschen doof allerdings klinge
das denke ich auch ohne gerüst wieder
ganz gut hin hier vorne unseren kleinen
provisorischen kommt auch mal abgebaut
wie kommt natürlich auch eine absperrung
dumm rum und zwar wird die 1
skizzieren sie alles live wird 1234 da
drauf kommen dann auch die eisengitter
zack zack hier vorne kommen dann auch
das kann ich euch ganz kurz schon mal
zeigen dann wisst ihr schon mal generell
wie alles aussieht kommen dann auch die
gräber hin nehmen dich hier vorne direkt
da habe ich mir gedacht nämlich seelen
sand und der geht das geräusch wenn man
seriös ansätze sec creepy das eigentlich
ist überhaupt nicht wie es hört sich
echt nach seelen an so ein bisschen auf
jeden fall lange dass hier eine
steintreppe hinkommt und hier fordere
habe ich mir dann extra einige schilder
mitgenommen so dass wir sagen können
beispielsweise hier ruht das schwein und
dann machen wir genau das gleiche hier
vorne da kommt dann auch noch ein grab
hin
wir setzen hier noch mal eben kurz das
durchsehen sand und den blog hier vorne
ersetzt mir auch dich sehen sind wenn
man hier beispielsweise hinschreiben
hier ruht die kuh fertig und dann kommt
hier außen rum das passt perfekt kommt
dann so eine kleine absperrung ich weiss
ist jetzt leider wahrscheinlich
schreiben geht da können aber tiere
drüber laufen ja ich weiß also könnt ihr
drauf habt dann könnt ihr hier darauf
hüpfen
allerdings wollte ich jetzt nicht
irgendwelchen steinmauern machen sondern
ein bisschen zum durchgucken die an den
seiten machen wir das allerdings ein
bisschen anders
da sollen nämlich wieder glatter steine
hinkommen und auch die gemeißelten
steinblöcke also hier
lauterstein eingemeißelt und noch ein
glatter stein und da oben seht ich schon
in meiner anderen hand befindet sich
eine laterne die kommt nämlich einmal
hierhin und hier oben kommt auch eine
laterne dran dafür habe ich mir extra
bruchstein stufen mitgenommen da sollen
nämlich hier eine dran dann hier oben an
den blog eine und hier so können wir
nämlich hier vorne mit einer laterne
dransetzen
und ich glaube ich werde auch mal ganz
kurz hier um nochmal im hochbauamt hat
jetzt ein krieg aber das war wieder nur
diese dumme spinne ich werde hier vorne
dran setzen ich glaube dass sie ein
bisschen besser aus sagt man damit dass
sie mich so ein bisschen als eingang
dass sie ganz cool dass mit dem bau
nicht ob das lassen wir einfach so und
ich mag es generell wenn wir so ein
bisschen natur hier mit drin haben hier
an der seite kommen auf jeden fall auch
123 und hier vorne auch vier ist jetzt
zwar ein bisschen blöd dass das alles
ein bisschen in der luft herum schwebt
aber das werden wir auf jeden fall noch
ein bisschen schöner bauen in ihr kommt
der kommt wieder weg
und hier muss auch noch ein bisschen
erde hin jetzt habe ich allerdings
leider nur vier stück ich glaube
allerdings ausreichen sollte zack zack
hier vorne kommen dann auch wieder
gräber hin da nehme ich auch wieder
meine stein ziegel treppen
sack und pack und dann nehmen wir auch
selbstverständlich wieder den sälen sand
und müssen dass hier einmal ganz kurz
versetzen zack zack zack zack
und hier kommen wir auch schilder dran
ich weiß ich ja noch verstorben war ich
da aber das war doch ein schwein und
schafft hier ruht das schaf und haben
ihr fleisch bekommt man von kaninchen
[Musik]
das kaninchen habe ich einfach mal das
waren auf jeden fall die 4 bode die wir
hier zu beklagen hatten
die von unserer insel hinten weiß ich
nicht genau wie ich auf die ob ich hier
auf diese ebenso mit übernehmen will
denn die sache ist dass hier eigentlich
dafür schon ein grabstein auf meiner
insel haben das müsstet ihr mann in die
kommentare schreiben
wie ihr das ganze seht ich muss mir auch
demnächst auf jeden fall noch ein
bisschen mehr erde mitnehmen und das
hier ein bisschen schöner machen
allerdings sollen die seiten hier
wirklich auch so ein bisschen beleuchtet
sein von daher muss ich das hier vorne
jetzt so ein bisschen erst mal so machen
wir schauen uns das natürlich nachher
nochmal genauer an und werden das auch
nach dem fertigstellen
allerdings werde ich das jetzt so erst
mal durchziehen und hier vorne dann
einmal kurz umziehen da euch eine ganz
große teilnetz einblenden
so ich habe den ganzen friedhof jetzt
mal eingezäunt der eingang ist auch mehr
oder weniger schon fertig wir sind
komplett fertig hier vorne den weg muss
man es machen allerdings meine schaufel
ja kaputt gegangen ich habe die schilder
hier vorn jetzt aber daran gemacht hier
vorne fehlt noch ein schild eben und
mehr schilder habe ich auch gerade gar
nicht da muss ich noch mal ganz kurzem
einer werkbank hier hinten laufen
beziehungsweise dieses steht ja hier
hinten um ihr noch kurz drei weitere
schilder zu machen ändern wenn ich laut
und sie schon wieder die ganzen blöcke
also einmal hier eben zack zack zack
zack und dann oft eben 123 und sagt
anita bekomme e3 stellt daraus und er
sollte das passen einmal ganz kurz
wieder zurücklaufen dann kann ich auch
schon mal an bringen ich hab mir gedacht
bevor wir uns dann immer wieder neue
schild nehmen müssen falls irgendwas
passieren sollte haben wir die schilder
dann hier auf jeden fall schon mal am
start also hier vorne fehlt noch eins
beim und hier hinten fehlt auch noch
eins jetzt gehe ich noch mal ganz gut
schlafen heut schon hier in der mitte da
fehlt noch irgendwas das werdet ihr
gleich sehen was da hin kommt also
einmal ganz kurz schlafen gehen und dort
kommt jetzt eine art großes grab hin
eventuell kennt ihr das von friedhöfen
diese ändern
ich bin echt freche haben die ganze zeit
meine sachen auch schaut mal wie schön
das aussieht das ignorieren wir also ihr
kennt es ja vielleicht von friedhöfen
dass da irgendwie immer ein dings ist
sich noch einmal ganz kurzen schaufel
[Musik]
gleichzeitig die werkbank nochmal mit
dem was sich allerdings gerade sagen
wollte war eventuell kenne das von
friedhöfen dass man da so herläuft und
dann sieht man die ganz normalen so
privaten gräber sage ich jetzt mal ein
bisschen kleiner sind und so und dann
gibt's halt ab und zu so richtig riesige
räder die dann meistens für
irgendwelchen pastoren gehören oder zum
bürgermeister oder irgendwie so deswegen
habe ich mir gedacht mache ich hier ganz
am ende auch ein großes grab hin genauso
wie mainz auf der insel von mir auf
meiner heimat insel wo allerdings
niemand unterliegt sondern was einfach
ein bisschen über allem thronen soll und
dem friedhof einen namen geben soll und
diesen namen für den friedhof den dürft
ihr bestimmen ich habe jetzt gar nicht
genug sand mit um das hier alles
aufzustocken ob ich doch die habe ich
auf jeden fall noch eine menge am start
denn ich brauche noch ein bisschen
ärgern gleich diesen weg da ein bisschen
schöner zu machen und die schaufel habe
ich mir gerade schon gemacht also hier
vorne mache ich gleich mal weiter hier
vorne es muss halt alles noch aufstocken
das mache ich hier erst mal ganz kurz
mit er mit sand das machen wir dann
nachher noch mit der vernunft nicht
fertig allerdings erst mal kurz den weg
hier fertig machen damit ihr wisst wo
die reise hingeht und sagt dann kommt
man quasi hier suchen wir haben ein
bisschen beleuchtung und hier der mitte
seht ihr auch schon fehlt halt ein
bisschen was deswegen habe ich mir eine
menge bruchstein mitgenommen setzt immer
hier rein bamm bamm bamm bamm
und da ziehen jetzt an den seiten erst
mal die
[Musik]
ich bin
ich habe einige glatte steine vergessen
ist allerdings auch kein problem dann
habe ich gerade noch geholt ja ich noch
in der kiste
hier vorne ich glaube das sieht schon
ganz geil aus wenn wir dann hier
demnächst auch so eine kleine kirche und
seine kapelle stehen haben das geht sehr
sehr sehr sehr wild generell sie schon
kommen dass wir uns mehr auf unsere tier
insel aufhalten als auf unserer normalen
insel aber so bald soll es natürlich
nicht kommen ich nehme jetzt mal ganz
kurz martenstein und zeigt euch was ich
mir für die seiten überlegt hatte
denn da kommen die hierhin und so und
jetzt nehmen uns unsere ganzen
bruchsteinmauern und ziehen das thema so
ein bisschen hoch nämlich 1 2 1 2 1 2 1
und jetzt sind die mitte auch und zack
zack zack und jetzt drauf springen kann
ich nicht mehr ist allerdings auch kein
problem sagt das machen wir gleich am
ende fertig jetzt müssen wir uns
allerdings erstmal hier ganz kurz hoch
bauen denn ich muss jetzt hier erstmal
das dach drauf setzen
jetzt ist natürlich ganz gut wenn ich
jetzt irgendwie dings mit dabei hätte
wenn ich jetzt ein bisschen ein gerüst
mit hätte aber das ist jetzt auch nicht
weiter schlimm es ist krieg hier volle
auch schon easy gebacken hier einmal
ganz kurz hoch bauen hier drauf bamm
bamm bamm bamm und die letzte können wir
auch leben von hier unten draufsetzen
da setzen jetzt auf der anderen seite
die treppen auch wieder so hin dass
wisst ja dass ich das immer ganz gut
finde wenn man diese gegeneinander sei
zwar ein bisschen smuda aussieht und
hier vorne rum auch noch mal und jetzt
müssen wir noch einmal ganz kurz
obendrauf denn da kommt jetzt
selbstverständlich auch noch ein
bisschen die bruchstein stufen darauf
die sollen nämlich so angeordnet werden
hier so ein bisschen als nach oben
drüber sack und pack und jetzt auf der
seite einmal durchziehen und auf der
seite einmal die laien durchziehen jetzt
hier vorne ein mal eben kurz unser
gerüst wieder abgebaut bzw
die bruchsteine einfach auf der seite
und hier vorne auch wenn wir müssen nur
noch einmal ganz kurz hoch da können wir
aber dass sie eben kurz nutzen denn hier
in der mitte soll die mauer hochgezogen
werden
denn das machen wir jetzt so sack und
pack die hier bauen wir mal eben kurz
wieder ab und jetzt müssen wir uns noch
einmal ganz kurz hoch bauen das jetzt
komm ich nicht hoch
aber gleich auch so hin sagt und jetzt
gehen wir ganz gut unterstützt das ganze
hier mal eben an und lasst euch ich euch
das oft mal ganz guten zeige was ich mir
da gedacht habe und zwar soll das ein
bisschen so aussehen dass jetzt nicht ob
das so gut aussieht ich glaube ich
könnte ich hier auch noch so ein schild
dran machen und dann können wir da dran
schreiben wir den ganzen die katheter
endermann die ganze zeit hier amrum
touren was ich sagen wollte war dass ich
da noch mal ein schild dran packer dann
wissen wir nämlich genau wie der
friedhof heißt beziehungsweise was
könnten daran schreiben platziert erst
mal so dann kann man irgendwas
hinschreiben als wenn ihre idee habt wie
dieser friedhof hier heißen soll oder
was ich da drauf schreiben sondern
schreibt gerne und in die kommentare
normalerweise würde ich das wieder an
der stelle jetzt beenden denn den
friedhof wir haben wir fertig wir haben
die verstorbenen tiere scharf kaninchen
schwein und kuh die er hier durch die
triebwerks besondere die luft gegangen
sind
das haben wir fertig die liegen hier
unten da könnten wir eigentlich auch mal
ganz kurz
geschweige sekunde verein binden hier
noch ein paar weiße tulpen und hier
vorne noch eine sonnenblume und ihre
noch ein ziel auch hier ist hier auch
noch hierhin beispielsweise hier vorne
hier und sagt 'das haben auf jeden fall
genug platz hier fanden dass bienen das
erste heißt es wie so viele tiere
mittlerweile schon haben wir auf jeden
fall genug platz um eigentlich alles
mitzunehmen was sich hier vorne in der
kiste drin befindet deswegen wollen wir
mal ganz kurz ab und die werkbank die
kirche stehen das ja überall genug
werkbänke das reisebett nehme ich noch
mal ganz kurzen mit ich weiß auch dass
wir hier vorne
das noch nicht so ganz fertig haben hier
mit der dings aber das werde ich auf
jeden fall im nächsten machen erfahren
wir heute nicht mehr so viel zeit die
folge soll nicht so lange wenn ich habe
auch gar nicht so viel zeit ich möchte
allerdings da immer diese folgen jedoch
so ein bisschen thematisch themenbezogen
folgend haben
macht überhaupt keinen sinn ich kann
allerdings auch nicht mehr richtig
sprechen ich habe mir nur gedacht weil
den folgen immer dass ich lieber eine
sache dann in einer voll gemacht und die
folgen mit ein bisschen länger als dass
ich das dann eben über 34 folgen zieht
jedoch habe mir nach vorne doch ein
kleines malheur was uns passiert ist mit
dem creeper deswegen stock ich das jetzt
noch mal ganz kurz auf hier fordert
schon wieder eine schildkröte
es ist mir egal was du für eine
vorgeschichte kann es natürlich
selbstverständlich da drinnen bleiben
ich konzentriere mich hier vorne auf das
klima doch was sie vorne wieder an start
gegangen ist das kannst du dir doch
bitte ich dich aus denken dass wir immer
so ein pech gehabt mit diesen ganzen mob
selber gut mache ich dementsprechend
hierbei jetzt einfach mal eine
verabschiedung einer lieben freunde wenn
es euch gefallen hat ihr heute die voll
gemein schaft mitbürger dann lass gern
einen daumen hoch unter dem video hier
da abonniert main kanal falls doch ein
teil der natur seite und klickt auf die
glocke in den neue videos nicht
verpassen wollte und eine
benachrichtigung bekommen möchte sobald
ich ein neues video hochladen
so sind jetzt eigentlich schon relativ
gut fertig damit ich glaube so saß aus
hier den weg kann ich natürlich erst
machen wenn das alles neu gewachsen ist
buch steinstufen habe ich noch mit am
start von der kann ich auf jeden fall
schon mal eine hinsetzen allerdings sah
es ja so nett war aus hier vorne fehlt
noch ein bisschen was von dem baum und
kann ich noch mal ganz kurz ein bisschen
runter ziehen und ich glaube hier war
auch noch erde am start deswegen setze
ich die hier auch noch mal eben prozent
nach und sagt hier vorne ist ja nix mehr
mit am start hier fehlt noch eine
margerite ich glaube die habe ich hinten
auf die insel aussehen gesetzt aber auch
egal meine lieben freunde ländern der
stelle wie bereits gesagt würde ich
heute gibt die so dass auch beenden wir
sehen uns übermorgen wieder um 20 uhr
ihr könnt mir jetzt gerne in die
kommentare schreiben wie ich den
friedhof benennen soll und
er gibt zu einander
[Musik]